I mean first of all I want to jack your
outfit that's so cool I like your dress
it's so cute I didn't know sparkly until
I came in the mail and I was like
surprised that's like perfect for stage
I know that's like the stuff I look for
like whenever per form or whatever
because it catches the light it's really
pretty you have the same name I know
this is old news to y'all but it's so
funny to me is it hard like when people
are does it ever get confusing with
emails or questions or yeah what's the
most difficult part the male mail yeah
mail it's yours no it's yours yeah like
this holiday season's going to be tough
like there's going to be some gifts
ruined for
sure opening up of the wrong that's
amazing um TSA like check-ins at the
airport back in they get they're like we
need Taylor and we're like that's both
hi yes hello we are both like no Taylor
lner and we're like also oh my gosh it's
just kind of incredible that you found
each other like it's just I don't know
one person named like in my personal
life the fact that there's yeah okay
yeah well now you got it's not as
popular I don't think to me so now I'm
like yeah so wait so your first
anniversary is coming up right it is
yeah are youall doing something fun
first
one what yeah we are we're actually
doing a fundraising Gala for our
nonprofit for our anniversary yeah we're
super excited about it did you purposely
do something not for you like but for
others I mean we've we've been
waiting to do our first Gala or
fundraising evening um for the nonprofit
and it just felt right we when we were
talking about what we wanted to do for
the anniversary we like should we go
somewhere blah blah blah we like or we
could you know we love like sentimental
things so like it just it just like felt
right I think it's beautiful I think
it's a beautiful thing to do on your
[Music]
anniversary
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home